this is the jocko unraveling podcast
episode six with daryl cooper and me
jocko willink
so i'm
coming home leaving this place of
turmoil and chaos that has escalated
throughout my
deployment in 2003 2004
and on my way home actually was before i
left
my commanding officer who have
referenced a bit
who i was friends with
you know he told me that his last
mission
as the commander of seal team seven
was going to be to make me the admiral's
aide
and the reason that he wanted to do it
was a good reason
primarily because i was a platoon
commander
that was coming off the battlefield in
iraq
there was it for an intent for a
six-month deployment and so i was sort
of
the most combat experienced lieutenant
in the navy that
was available for that type of bullet so
it's a good move you know let's get the
boss let's get the admiral
some guys that are a guy that's fresh
off the battlefield that's done a bunch
of
missions that can talk to him and and
explain to him what's happening and give
him the support that he needs
and it was you know it's a it's a it's a
move that he wanted to take care of me
too because when you're
the admiral's aide you know you develop
a relationship with the admiral and you
meet every single
other seal admiral and every single seal
captain and every single seal commander
and so you know you build a bunch of
really good relationships you get to
know people in the community and you get
to see what the community's like
so so i imagine there was an element of
uh
yeah he wants to help you out in your
career but also next time you go back to
iraq he wants you in charge of more than
a platoon
yeah i'd say maybe but i i don't i don't
think that was
really what it was i think he really
just number one
primarily he wanted to get me you know
i'm i'm a guy
and you know i've sent you some things
that we're not going to share
the kind of the i'm a direct
i i d i will not hold back right i mean
if there's something that's happening
that needs to change
i will state my opinion i'll do it
tactfully
and if you listen to me that's great and
if you don't listen to me i
might not be so tactful you know i'm
gonna i'm gonna
yeah i think you know you ever heard
that cheesy expression speaks truth to
power
sure it's a cheesy expression right yeah
i i have the receipts you do do that
no that that he wrote that in my
evaluation like speaks truth
to power right because i would tell him
with something if i didn't like
something that he was doing and you know
we had a good relationship i wasn't ever
disrespectful about it you know we'd
have good conversations and
sometimes he'd tell me to shut up and
i'd say roger that sir and yeah that's
the way it is but
i would i would explain to him my
viewpoint treating him with enough
respect to assume he wants the truth
yeah and and so he knew i would do that
with the admiral and so
he gets me that job so
i get home and take over
as the admirals aid and
let's see so i get home in april
it's like probably mid to late april
when i get home i take over the job
and almost immediately after i take over
the job
um a guy by the name of brian olette
who was a seal was was killed in on
may 29 2004 in afghanistan
and so one of my first
jobs as the admiral's aide was to get
the admiral
out to brian olette's funeral
and so i knew i knew brian alette and
actually at this point there had been
brian was
i think the fifth seal killed so neil
roberts
fifi was the first seal killed
in in march of o2 and
i knew nielsen's hill team 2 with with
neil
and then matt bourgeois was the second
seal killed also in afghanistan and that
was also in march of o2
and it was i was a team one with him so
i was like two for two or o for two
depending on how you want to look at it
and then tom retzer and and
dave tapper were um
were also were also killed and they they
were killed in o3
so and i knew those guys
but i didn't know them as well
as i knew neil robertson and matt
bourgeois
only because i had been at a team with
those guys and i hadn't been on a team
with
retzer or tapper but i knew him just
from being around
and i remember my parents asking me you
know
every time a seal would get killed
they'd say did you know him and and i'd
say
yes and it was very strange that
well then i knew brian olette as well
and i had gone he was a couple
buds classes ahead of me and so i knew
him from that
and then we went through a comms like a
two-month calm school
together and we hung out a bunch during
that he was just a
uh just a straight up um
you know stereotypical new englander
from from needham massachusetts
and you know he had great accent and a
great attitude and he was you know
boisterous and funny and all those
things
and when he got killed so i knew him
and when he got killed you know i'm the
admiral's aide and we're going you know
we're going to the
the funeral and
he had his mom his dad he had six
brothers
i think he was six brothers and a sister
and they were lined up
like to shake hands with people and you
know
um it was like you were looking at just
clones like
the his dad looked like brian or brian
looked like his dad and then his all his
brothers looked the same you seem lined
up and
almost got their their own platoon yeah
he almost got his own platoon and you
just you just could feel the
the just absolute you know heartbreak
um and i hadn't been to i hadn't been to
any other you know any other
funerals like that so
that was kind of my welcome aboard to
working with the admiral
was was helping him supporting him as he
was seeing off you know
the the first seal that he was going to
lose under his command you know as
as the admiral so
there was a couple things too that that
as we went forward there was another
prisoner abuse scandal that happened
yeah and it was
with seals actually and what happened
was
seals had taken pictures and
uh these some one of the guys in the
platoon posted them on some kind of
photo sharing
site and the photo sharing site wasn't
protected or got hacked or whatever
whatever happened happened but
all of a sudden these pictures became
public and
this is what this is when i thought
about it was a good job for my
commanding officer to have put
me as the admiral's aide because when
this unfolded
there was a lot of these pictures that
they actually if you
interpreted them correctly then they
actually made sense
and so there were several multiple times
where you know i would be looking at
these pictures that the public was
seeing
and they looked awful and my boss the
admiral had to answer to
you know the secretary of the navy the
chief of naval operations
and i was able to explain to him exactly
what's going on these pictures so
a couple examples are one of them is
you know a seal holding a guy holding
you know
an iraqi guy by the jaw and you know
kind of around the throat around the jaw
and he's got his pistol pointed at
at the guy's head and you know my boss
says
what's going on here well you know this
is horrible and i said here's what's
going on sir
these insurgents do not want to have
their pictures taken by us
so they won't look at the camera they'll
look away so a lot of times you got to
hold their head in position
so that someone can take a picture and
in order to take a picture you gotta
have lighting
and the quickest available light that we
all use
is our pistol the light's on the pistol
you pull it out you
illuminate the guy that's what's going
on in this picture okay got it
next picture um guy with a
sandbag on his head uh blood
dripping out of the sandbag and you know
okay what's going on in this picture
sir in this picture you've got a
insurgent that was probably captured
four minutes or ten minutes before this
picture was taken
he resisted that's what these insurgents
do
they resist according to the rules of
engagement
you can kill them when they resist and
what we try not to do is kill people if
we don't have to
so this guy was probably hit with a
couple muzzle strikes
gotten con you know they got him under
control they put a bag over his head and
he's bleeding from his nose or from his
whatever his forehead from getting hit
with a muzzle that's what the blood is
this is actually this this picture
actually demonstrates the
restraint that seals show on target
because they didn't shoot and kill this
guy
so those are the kind of questions that
i was you know able to answer
um but nonetheless you know those
pictures
without context they just look bad and
those added to you know they added to
the abu ghraib photos they weren't as
bad
but they weren't good either what was
your impression of how
admiral mcguire uh responded to it i
mean you respond to it like a
guy who was a seal or not you know
politician
no he was great good he was great he was
uh he was
you know listened to what i had to say
he you know
we had discussions about it i heard him
explain
up the chain of command you know he was
he's a very
you know he's he's a he's a great guy
and he understood
you know when i explained it to him he's
like okay you know he was he's a seal he
understood
what i was talking about and he was able
to articulate it even better than me to
to his boss he watched one of his
congressional hearings when he was
briefly the acting dni and he just
seemed like a
straight shooting guy just a direct and
and he's uh you know he's a guy that
bill he's a great relationship builder
because he's a nice guy you know he was
a guy that always cared about seal
platoons
you know he always cared about sales
always the the one of the biggest
lessons i learned from him is
he's gonna his mission was to take care
of the seal platoons
and there's plenty of people in the
military and civilian sector where they
lose sight of what it is that they're
actually supposed to be doing as a
leader
and what he was trying to do was take
care of seal platoons which is
exactly what he should have been doing
and and what we needed him to do
and what did that mean it means instead
of years you were there it means that
instead of
trying to look out for you know um
some in trying to look out
instead of trying to look out for the
officer community and how it's going to
compete against the fleet it's like no
how does this help us seal platoon
instead of looking at what about the
acquisitions that are going to take
place in the next four years can we get
more money here or there
hey does it help us seal platoon you
know he was constant and
if it helped the seal platoon to get
that acquisition in four years
or to build this officer structure
certain way he would do it if it wasn't
gonna help the seal platoons
then he wasn't gonna expend our
resources on it because there's all
kinds of things you can expend resources
on
you know like and and he would look at
it and say how can this
help a sealed platoon and by doing that
that's that's what we do that's what the
seal teams is seal teams boils down to a
seal plate
and the better supported they are the
better they can accomplish their mission
i think a lot of people have a
misapprehension they think of like a
naval officer and it's like a guy with a
cigar on the bridge of a ship
you're talking about an admiral that's
like a ceo yeah you're running a
gigantic organization yep huge amounts
of money and personnel
i mean yeah and and if you think that
because you're a navy seal admiral that
you're
out in the field with a machine gun
that's also not a good impression
because that's not what's happening and
much of what the
admiral was focused on was what's going
to happen in eight years
you know what where are we going to be
in 12 years where is our community
community going to be in three years you
know it wasn't
you know he obviously is dealing with
stuff that's happening ongoing as well
but in that position you actually
you train equip and then send on
deployment
the troops right you man train and equip
and then they go on deployment they're
not working for the admiral when they're
overseas
you're working for some you know special
operations
task force that's overseas or you're
getting chopped over to some
conventional units so
he's he's not doing that he's man
training equipped that was that was his
mission and he and he did it great
and you know i was i was very lucky to
to have that job and to work for a guy
that was you know
um very willing to try and teach me as
much as he could
let me sit in every meeting you know i i
mean i sat in meetings
you know the characters that that we're
talking about you know we're
sitting in meetings with rumsfeld
sitting sitting like i've been and
sitting in those meetings you know
as the not even close i was the most
junior guy by you know
by five ranks and and just sit there you
know sit there in the back and
and listen and those were
that was an awesome learning experience
and those are things that
gave me um a much
better understanding when i went to
ramadi had a much better understanding
of how these civilians
interacted with our military
so i'm very lucky to learn a lot from
that
i want to hear about that i mean expand
on that a little bit what do you mean
well you know when you're when you're at
the building as they call it
which is what the military folks call
the pentagon they call it the building
when you're in there
you start to understand the
interoperability and the chain of
command
and the politics that go on just
broadens your you just broadened your
scope you know when you're out there
you know when i was a platoon commander
you know my chain of command
you know kind of stopped at my boss
maybe the sigison of commander so my
boss's boss is like okay
i i i can kind of i can kind of grasp
what's going on there
then once you see the the other end the
the the most senior you know when you're
sitting in a room with the
we know the secretary of defense you're
starting to see the top down
and you start to see where what kind of
things are are
being thought about at that level and
the other thing was
and this was this was purposeful um
you know when i came back i was uh uh a
guy fresh off the battlefield
so i was a a kind of a kind of a little
bit of a zoo animal
right for for the admiral and and not
just for the admiral and
i don't mean that in a derogatory way
but
but he had the opportunity to take a guy
because
you know um going to brief
you know the the the whatever
level of senior leadership you want to
talk about i've briefed them
other than the president i never briefed
the president but
everyone else like i sat in the room and
briefed those people and explained to
them what
what was going on in baghdad and what it
seemed like to me and what we did and
what our mission was
and there were some of those meetings
that you know i'd walk away from those
meetings feeling
not too excited about some of the
attitudes and some of the
some of the questions that i'd be asked
um
there were some so it was good it was
good for me to see that it was good for
me to have the opportunity to do that
and i ended up doing again when you know
years later when i got back from ramadi
but i was very i got a great education
from that job and
he he had an attitude of you know not
only
getting me educated but using me to
educate
other people in the chain of command you
know about what
we were doing and what was going on over
there
so the you know
the the job i think i was there for 13
months
um i was
like getting ready to transfer and go
be a task unit commander seal team three
and uh
you know the the new guy shows up and
you know he's
another you know junior or another
lieutenant and he
forget where he was coming from the same
thing you know he had combat experience
coming back off the battlefield and he
was taking over from me
and a really great guy and you know he
he he says to me um what do you
how does the admiral morat how does the
admiral react
if you make a mistake and i looked at
him i said
i don't know because i really hadn't
dropped the ball
uh luckily um and
he just laughed and said oh man you know
so so
as we're completing the turnover i think
it's like
literally the day that i say you know
you got it
i'm out of here um as this is unfolding
um there's an operation that was taking
place in afghanistan
and we're right as we're wrapping up
this turnover
you know we have uh
operation red red wings happened and you
know we got guys on the ground
the um the qrf comes in on the
helicopter
the the the helicopter
you know gets hit goes down uh
we lose we lose 11 seals
um eight night stalkers
on the aircraft as well um and
[Music]
yeah like just just absolutely
horrible and you know i
and i was i was there right as this was
happening like right as i was leaving
we were getting reports that they were
getting radio they were getting
radio transmission it was marcus was
marcus luttrell like i was
hearing you know i'm sitting in the room
where they're telling the admiral
hey we've got we've got radio traffic we
think we think one of the guys might be
alive
and um and i to be honest with you
i i was thinking to myself you know it'd
been
been like a day or two and i'm thinking
yeah
well obviously some enemy has captured
his radio and they're doing whatever to
to make us think a guy's still alive and
by the grace of god i mean marcus you
know survived that
made it out and that was
that was like right that was right as i
turned over and and i remember the poor
guy that took over for me
as the aide you know the it's kind of
like the first major thing i did was one
funeral well his first major thing was
just a
complete the biggest disaster it's a
nightmare
and um and and then
you couple that with the fact that at
that time
so now i'm checking in to seal team
three to take over as a task unit
commander
and one of the first things that we did
as a task unit
was go to the memorial service
for these guys over in coronado
and you know it was um just
a total uh
it was crazy it was crazy to go to that
it was
uh you know obviously we are all now
completely focused
that was in afghanistan um we weren't
really sure we were going but we still
did we
the the the writing on the wall it
looked like we were going to iraq you
know that
most likely well either iraq or some
like like some non-combat deployment
to pacom or something like that but it
looked like we would be going to iraq
but definitely the way to
that was a that was a way to start a
training cycle with tasking a bruiser
that was very
we were focused you know we were focused
like you know you talk about
not watching videos well like our we
watched videos like our
training cadre would show us videos of
you know mujahideen fighters going
through our brother seals
gear and you know it's it was sickening
and it's one of those things that i
think
mentally really got us you know focused
on what we were
had to do not that we weren't focused
anyways but trust me that
that ups the game when did you find out
what your mission would be
so we formed up we started our work up
and once we started our work up there
was actually some
debate over who what task unit was going
to go to
iraq and the debate was some guys hadn't
been to iraq yet
and some guys had been to iraq there was
one task unit that
had not been to iraq and they said okay
those guys are they needed two
two task units in iraq they took one of
them and said you guys didn't go last
time you guys are going this time so
now there was two task units left that
we needed to decide which one of these
two task units would go to iraq
we my commanding officer actually called
us back and said okay called me and
i had to go back for a meeting and said
listen here's the courses of action
we're thinking about
one of them is we kind of split up the
task and we take guys that haven't been
to iraq before we build a new task unit
and those guys go to iraq and then the
other guys that have been to iraq
already
can just go to you know one of these
non-combat deployments
to pacom to the pacific and or
we just go and see who performs better
and whoever performs better goes to iraq
and um you know obviously my immediate
thought was yeah we
whoever performs better we go and if my
task unit doesn't perform better than
the other task
we don't deserve to iraq and let them go
you know that's may the best man win
um the other task commander was more
like hey maybe it's the fairest thing to
mix up the task units i went back and
went back out to the desert because we
were in the middle of training and i
told my guys what the options were
and i told them what i thought and they
were like we're sticking together of
course
so we pushed back to just stick together
and
the commanding officer said roger that
best
whichever task unit is you know performs
we'll we'll send them to iraq and so we
did we performed really well
and the other option was a non-combat it
was an online combat
deployment to pay payments and both
those task units are competing
hard yeah it's it's definitely it's
definitely a hardcore competition
um every seal wants to go to war
well a solid 90 of seals want to go to
war by 06 every seal wants to go to war
yeah and that's the interesting thing so
we're forming this up as this is o5 and
you still have
just by the nature of that very decision
you have you have um
uh some seals that hadn't been to iraq
in fact a lot of seals hadn't been to
iraq yet
you know so i told you when i was
deploying with the navy
i was doing independent deployments
supporting swift and seal operations
fighting islamic insurgents down in the
philippines mm-hmm
a lot of people don't know there's
there's a lot of stuff going on all over
the world so yep
and and those deployments those you know
nothing against those deployments those
are
necessary deployments they're doing good
work as you just said
but you know doing doing what those guys
were doing there
there which again outstanding you know
thank you
uh necessary and important missions
for freedom and democracy
but we all want to go to iraq
we wanted we wanted to do more and as
much as we possibly could so we want to
go to iraq so
yep we get to iraq i actually did a
pre-deployment so we do our workup
we get selected to go to iraq we
go on i go on a pre-deployment
site survey pdss and when i go over
we go to baghdad i meet the
task unit commander that's over there in
baghdad they're doing almost the exact
same thing
that i did on my first deployment which
was direct action missions
they were the big difference was they
were working with uh partner force
you know i didn't do any partner force
with iraqi
soldiers in 0-304 these guys are doing
everything with these highly trained
iraqi soldiers called the ictf
so they're running operations they're
doing direct action they're capturing
bad guys
um they're i went over there went out on
a couple missions with them
you know straightforward i'm like oh
yeah we got this this is
this is good to go um they had good
assets
they had you know it was nice they had a
ton of iraqi soldiers so you had a
pretty good
footprint to get out there uh look solid
so that was probably you know whatever a
month before deployment
so i come back kind of give everyone the
gouge so what we're doing you know it's
what we've been training for we're going
to baghdad we're going to work with this
partner of course we'll be doing direct
action missions
so cool high five everyone's pumped
everyone's psyched
and everyone goes on leave
pre-deployment leave and i didn't
go on leave but i'm going into work and
one day my boss comes in and says
hey there might be a change and i say
this is interesting ramadi
had backpedaled a little bit ramadi had
been
had it was now the new hotbed like i it
had been the new hotbed since
fallujah ended when fallujah when the
fallujah
um takedown was over the big marine
corps november 04.
when when that was over it took about
another month where everyone said oh
okay i guess it's ramadi now so ramadi
started heating up and
the intel reports and the after actions
reports and the incident reports
were in the sigint reports they were all
now looking at ramadi so
capital of ambar province the capital of
ambar province so now at some point
uh i put on the task unit bruiser door
for three or four days there was a
little sign that said uh
you know mayor of ramadi or something
like that like
i was gonna go be the mayor of ramadi i
want to go to ramadi
but it but that that was early it was
early on
and then it was a joke that it lasted
five minutes and then it didn't talk
about it again
actually matter of fact it was leif who
reminded me of that later like you
remember
saying that you were going to be the
mayor of ramadi and i was like oh yeah
yeah we had a little sign up or whatever
so so now
what had happened was there was a they
wanted to align
there was so now there's two sealed
teams in iraq and they wanted to
align geographically more geographically
aligned
the two seal teams that are in iraq and
that meant
the west of iraq so fallujah habenia
ramadi would be west coast seals and
then like
baghdad and wherever else the eastern
eastern iraq was going to be a different
seal team
so the only switch that it took to make
that happen was ramadi that was the only
one that was
for some reason however it got sorted
out before
you had ramadi and that was that was a
an east coast seal team and and the
other
fallujah and habaneria were west coast i
think
but anyways i don't i don't remember it
100 but i know that there was
ramadi was the key component that needed
to switch
and so my boss said hey what would you
think about instead of going to baghdad
you went to ramadi and i was like
you know i'm like yeah so absolutely it
was my immediate thought
and was it clear at this point that this
is a whole different type of mission
no so i'm
but i just know that there's more bad
guys yeah and there's a lot of bad
[ __ ] going on there and what i i want in
my life is bad [ __ ] to be going on and
reminding you
he had a new mayor at that point i mean
this is the capital not only of ambar
province this was the capital of
the island yeah it's supposed to be the
the capital of the caliphate that's what
it was
what that's what it's hoping to be uh so
i remember i i utilized this request
to make some deals with my boss to get
you know i said i need this this and
this i said i'll go to ramadi i need
this this and this it was like
random things like i needed some like
you you well you may or may not know so
there was some
there was some satellite uh internet
system
that we didn't have allotted to us and i
was like i need that i need this other
thing i need more people i need this
and my boss kind of laid it out and used
that as bargaining chips
with the the other commander and sorted
it out and i got
basically everything that i wanted and i
got to go to ramadi so
so you're why the fifth fleet uh navy
lost all its inmarsat connections
it might be okay it might be yeah like
that kind of thing it was
beautiful and so i i when i said i was
super excited i didn't show my cards i
just was like
well you know we could do it let me look
at you know well let me look at what
i've got let me look at what's on the
ground over there let me see what i need
they're like giaco you have a boner yeah
yep yeah
so i so that's what happened so i
actually i don't remember if i called
the guys and let them know i mean i know
i called the key leaders
and said hey guys we're not going to bag
anymore we're going to ramadi
but i don't think i even called the the
e-dogs you know they were they were on
leave man they don't care
they don't care they didn't discriminate
they're kind of like me you know you
asked me if i knew the mission was gonna
be totally different
i didn't think the mission was gonna be
totally different i just thought it
would be more action
i didn't know that we would do something
completely different
and you didn't know what would be riding
on it like did you have an idea of that
no no i just knew there was more bad
guys there
and that's where i wanted to be and
that's what i wanted that's where i know
everyone
what in my task unit wanted to be so
that's where it kicks off we we
well they're about 30 35 of you guys
yeah there's so there's
technically there's 36 guys in the task
unit
you know two 16 man seal platoons and a
headquarters element
but then so that's that's the seals and
then there's another
uh i think my my cam my account normally
in camp was around 100
so the support personnel so right radium
and seabees
um uh armory guys supply guys
uh we had a we ended up having a couple
marines that ran radio like we
so we end up with about 100 guys you
know 40
or so support or no sorry 60 or so
support 40 or so seals
something like that is generally what it
looked like did you understand at least
that this was a city
that it's not quite right to say we had
no presence in but i mean
we were as i've heard it from some
journalists and from people who were
over there
we were you were going into a city that
there were parts of it where
the civilians may not have seen an
american uniform in 8 10
12 months absolutely i knew that our
people were
basically sitting in static defense
positions occasionally running out on
patrols and getting shot at the entire
time i mean this was a city where
that the insurgents largely controlled
the insurgents controlled a lot of it um
and when we got there it was the 228 was
the pennsylvania national guard that was
on the ground and
and to say that they were sitting behind
now they were out getting after it
and they were they were pushing hard
they were pushing really hard
and they were very experienced
you know they'd been on the ground i
think the number's 14 months i always
say 14 months
i heard it from one of them at some
point but
they'd been on the ground for a long
time fighting hard so all of us seals
that have been through navy seal
training or whatever
these guys had way more combat
experience than we had okay and
you know we knew that as soon as we got
on the ground that
it was really obvious as soon as you get
on the ground that this was not i mean
even even in comparison to baghdad i
mean you go out of
the like i we ended up in this little
um little saddam vacation house i guess
is what it'd be it's like a small
mansion on the euphrates river and
you go out at night onto the onto the
deck
and look at the city in the city you're
going to see you're seeing explosions
and you're seeing
you know tracer fire like you know like
a like
a war movie that's what it looked like i
mean in fact
you're getting a target and you're going
after them
in ramadi they're coming for you i mean
this is a this is a city that they
expect the insurgents expect to control
and they are mounting a tax on our
fortified positions
right yes absolutely they are mounting
attacks on our fortified positions
they have maneuver elements they have
qrf
they are using combined arms they are
using communications
they are on the attack no doubt
so you get you guys ready well we show
up there and
the first thing we're doing is we're
turning over with the guys that are
there and they're giving us good solid
turnover
um uh of what they've been doing how
they've been doing it
they had been continuing to focus on uh
doing trying to do direct action
missions working with some of the iraqi
soldiers
that's what they had kind of been
focused on
they had been trying to still do
unilateral operations meaning operations
where it's just seals
and they were getting shut down on that
and it took me
three minutes to decide okay well we're
not going to try and do any unilateral
operations because
this was a time of by with and through
right so the the
the attitude had shifted that what we're
trying to do is get the iraqis
able to handle security in their own
country so
if you go on a mission you're taking
iraqis with you so that that's
where were these iraqis coming from at
the beginning uh in the beginning they
were they were
they were army soldiers but i mean iraqi
army soldiers
are all coming from almost all shia okay
vast majority shia occasional sunni
some kurds um but vast majority i mean
the sunnis were in a position by this
point in large parts of the country
where if they showed up to a recruiting
station their family's dead
if they show up to a polling station to
vote in one of these elections in 05
they're dead if you run for office
you're dead yeah i mean aqi had
consolidated control over the
in the 05 election i think there was 2
percent sunni turnout
i mean people just couldn't do it you
couldn't show up to work for the police
you couldn't be seen speaking to an
american
right and uh there were a lot of people
on the political side by this point who
were like
this is over you know ramadi's lost and
bar is lost and there is
nothing we can do short of turn that
place into a parking lot to get it back
i remember
there was i remember because it was on
september 11th and
it was the fifth anniversary of
september 11 2006
a report that had been going around
generated by the head of intelligence
for the marine corps
i'm sure you remember it colonel peter
devlin and this is
the fifth anniversary of september 11th
and you know the 10th anniversary 15th
anniversary we always have like
this is going to be kind of the articles
that come out in the washington post and
places like that which is where this is
they're kind of setting the conditions
where are we right
tom rick's put out he didn't have he
couldn't publish the report it was
classified but he put up part of it
it said chief of intelligence for the
marine corps in iraq recently filed an
unusual secret report concluding
that the prospects for securing that
country's western anbar province are dim
and that there is almost nothing the u.s
military can do to improve the political
and social situation there said several
military officers and officers and
intelligence officials familiar with its
contents
one army officer summarized it as
arguing that in anbar province
we haven't been defeated militarily but
we have been defeated politically
and that's where wars are won and lost
devlin reports that there are no
functioning iraqi government
institutions in anbar leaving a vacuum
that has been filled by the insurgent
group al qaeda in iraq
which has become the province's most
significant political force
said the army officer who has read the
report another person familiar with the
report
said that it describes anbar as beyond
repair a third said that it concludes
that the united states has lost in anbar
these people said he reported that
military operations are at a stalemate
unable to extend and sustain security
beyond the
perimeters of their bases and that's
where you guys are going
and you aren't being given a mission to
go
get us through the next six months we've
had a
strategic shift where some of the people
who are arguing for a more aggressive
policy to actually try to turn things
around
are being given an opportunity to show
that they can do it
yeah that was some of the meetings that
i went
that i was in in the building when i was
an admiral's aide
that's where i started hearing talk and
and
i started seeing um i started seeing two
sides
of the story and two opposing viewpoints
of what was happening
there was a side that was trying to
figure out how to win
and there was a side that was trying to
figure out how not to lose
and and you know trying to by
by saying trying to figure out how not
to lose it's like how to get out of
there
how to shut this thing down how do we
how do we get out of this without
just you know without egg on our face
and the other side of saying how are we
going to win
and and there was surprisingly there was
military and civilian people on both
sides of of that
of those two divergent opinions of
how we should move forward the obvious
one is president bush
president bush wanted to win he wanted
to win
and you could you you could sense that
you knew that you actually knew that he
wanted to win
you also could sense that there were
people
on civilian and military side
that believed that report right there
which was
we cannot win this thing it's a quagmire
not not just ramadi we were talking iraq
ramadi was the was the was the
exclamation point
was the example of why we cannot
this is impossible this isn't going to
work that that that's
that's the way it is so you definitely
i definitely heard both sides
of that of of of those opinions
sitting in the pentagon in in
meetings as a junior guy sitting in the
back of a room hearing discussions
between
high-level people and
yeah so when we got out there you know
we definitely knew
that it was gonna be bad and and for the
most part
you know what seals are looking at is
like you know okay how are we gonna win
you know our opinion is how we're gonna
win and it's it's even tighter than that
it's how are we gonna win tonight how
are we gonna win what are we gonna do
today to make an impact to make a
difference
and unfortunately what that can lead to
and it's not just seal so you talk about
any you know any company in below sized
element
you know whether it's a task you know
whether it's a company you know any
any small unit led by an 03 or or below
a platoon they're looking at like okay
what do i do today
how can i improve today and tomorrow
what can i do to fix this immediate
problem that's what you're looking at
so when we show up there
there's do you can you immediately know
i mean there's there's memorial services
almost every day and we're go you know
we almost immediately
we're going to memorial services for
soldiers and marines that are being
killed
um the you know there's like i said
there's more there's
mortar you know we're getting mortared
on base
and that's a pretty regular occurrence
there's
firefights out in the city all the time
and you know when you were in baghdad
like in baghdad first of all baghdad's
huge i mean it's huge geographically
it's more like la right ramadi is a
little tiny city
it's not a big place so when there's a
firefight going on you and you're in an
elevated position
if there's a firefight going on ramadi
you can see it like you can see any
tracer
you can you're going to be able to see
it from an elevated position so that
means that any time you get on a rooftop
at nighttime
you can see gunfire going on especially
when we first got there
there was a lot it seemed like the enemy
was
fighting during the night a little bit
more um
we they started to adjust their tactics
i think and fight more during the day
and then we are adjusted our tactics to
fight during the day as well
but we get there you go you you started
your deployment in march right when did
you get to ramadi
um well i got i just we started in april
i went right to right right
okay right to ramadi and i never left he
started prepping for i believe the
operation began
in earnest in june um
you know my goal was to start doing
operations as soon as we got there and
we did yeah
it was like as soon as life showed up
and stoner um
it was like strapping on boys and
you know i i had i had told both those
guys the two platoon commanders that
worked for me
um i will get i'm my goal is to you know
make you quit get you so much combat
that you come to me and say jocko i
can't take anymore and they said bring
it and they said bring it
and uh were you personally like are you
working for colonel mcfarland
i'm working for so when i get there it's
colonel gronski
who is 228 commander and
he was um so i'm working for the special
operations
chain of command which means you know
there's my boss
who's an o5 commander of seal team three
and he's working for the siege zone of
commander who's the colonel
in charge of all the special operations
in the ao
so so that's my actual chain of command
my relationship chain of command which i
have a relationship obviously my boss
but i made a relationship with
with the conventional commanders because
it's their battle space
and i want to help them win that's my
goal i mean ramadi's kind of spoken of
as a pretty
um as an important battle in showing i
mean
very innovative in how special
operations forces and conventional
forces worked together
in a way that hadn't really been
achieved with that level of success
before
relationships and and humility because
you know when you when you roll
in and you're going to uh going and
you're seeing these these kids getting
killed
you are going to think okay what can i
do to help
and the last thing you're thinking of is
hey i you know you guys should listen to
me
you're like what can i do to help you
guys in any way what can we do
and that was the attitude that i had um
to to try and move forward and try and
help the situation on the ground now
a few episodes ago we talked about
this um this beautiful mind wall
that i had built with all these targets
on it these link diagrams
so when i got to ramadi i there was
another
seal element in ramadi and
they were
they
they were set up there but they they
they had a like a small command center
there and they had
guys working out of other areas and i
knew the i knew the commander he was a
friend of mine
and so he had been in ramadi for a while
and i went down and you know like you
know linked up with him
and was uh
just you know he you know we were we're
friends you know he was telling me what
they've been doing and
i was you know he was giving me like a
brief of what was happening what to
watch out for all
standard kind of turnover stuff and his
intel officer
was actually the same intel officer that
i had had
at sealteam7 you know it was like
awesome so
and uh she was a female and so you know
i saw her
and we started talking and she started
kind of going through
you know what they'd been doing and then
she says well why don't you come and you
know come to the intel shop and i'll
show you what we're doing
and so i walk into the intel shop and on
the wall is this big giant link diagram
and it was basically the same thing that
i had left
you know two years earlier in o4
same big giant group of people
some little red lines through them some
little green lines
through them meaning they've been
captured or killed
and i thought to myself this is not a
good sign
because it's been two years and even
though
there's some red lines and green lines
here this this thing hasn't gotten any
smaller
and that was my wake-up call
that we
were gonna lose like what we were doing
is like a hack-worth
situation for me where you know
i'm i'm looking at this going this is
what hackworth was thinking
when he's coming to vietnam and he sees
the same battles being fought over and
over again with nothing
changing so i was looking at this going
wait a second
it's been two years and i'm just looking
at a big link diagram that has the same
number of people on it
as it was as it was when i left
this is not a good sign i went back to
my
to my tactical operation center i pulled
up the internet
and i downloaded the new brand new
i didn't think it was um out yet it was
a draft
version of the counter-insurgency manual
that had just been written by petraeus
and all his crew he's got a whole crew
of really
yeah the whole crew mcmaster um
this whole crew of guys that had written
this this
fm three tech 24.
i downloaded it and read it sat there
and read it and
i just thought okay how can we
change what we're doing because this is
this is
not this is what we're doing is not
working
this is a different situation than it
was when i left this is an insurgency
and you realize it's going to take more
than kicking people's asses to win this
thing
this is when i realized that we were in
a counter insurgency that we needed to
fight a counter insurgency
and that's what i started doing
colonel mcfarland knew that so colonel
mcfarland
had come from tal afar so so
shortly after we got there um it was
time for the 228 to go home
colonel gronski and all those brave
souls
from the national guard and their
adjacent units awesome guys and they
gave us incredible turnover you know
they
they they they did great they were just
amazing they were amazing
soldiers i think most people can't even
wrap their head around that when they
think national guard they think like
weekend stints and a little bit of
college money the idea that they're a
national guard
people holding the line in ramadi for
however long
13 14 months is out of control yep and
total professionals um and
saved our lives like they saved our
lives with the information they gave us
with the lessons that they taught us
you know our our guys were like
listening you know incredible yeah it's
like
and and props to my guys you know like
um
oh my gosh we're not just saying now
we're seals we know what we're doing
there's none of that
it was hey what do you guys think of
this you know what do you think of that
how do you how would you do this what do
you think of this route
like we're ready to listen
but it was time for them to go home
they've been there for 14 months so now
the 1-1 a.d comes in
when the 1-1 ad armor division comes in
colonel sean mcfarland at the time now
he's a general retired but
so he had come from talifar and up in
talafar
he had relieved mcmaster
so mcmaster had run the
the counterinsurgency model the seize
clear hold and build
the go out into the neighborhoods form
relationships he'd run that
model in talifar and it worked it worked
so well that by the time
mcfarland got there they didn't need a
brigade up there anymore all they needed
was a battalion
and so i and again i might be a little
bit off on these but
you know so they said okay you're going
to leave a battalion up there
to handle talifar because it's all but
good
which was a nasty place it was a nasty
place and now it's
all but tame it's all but peaceful and
um mcfarland comes down and is
is like he's he understands the plan
that needs to be executed he's going to
mimic what happened
up in talafar because he got the good
turnover
and mcfarland just a smart
open-minded humble guy that would look
at problems and
come up with an idea and if someone gave
him a better idea he'd say that's a
better idea
let's do that instead and so he had that
attitude coming down and
and that's why you know when you when in
the earlier episodes when you're talking
about
you know bremer and there's nothing that
makes me sicker
than ego's driving decisions and
and people that don't listen it's just
it's the worst
possible thing you know that's why i
always say when we'd fire a seal leader
later on in my career when we were
running
when i was running seal training for for
advanced
you know for sealed platoons and steel
task units when we would fire a seal
leader
the thing that we would fire the seal
leader for is because he would have a
big ego and was arrogant and wouldn't
listen to people
because that right there is what gets
people killed when you don't listen
and so mcfarland was
up smart and looked at what
mcmaster done and said that looked like
it worked to me and now you want
we'll go do it down in ramadi and this
is where we get to the point
with what you were talking about where
people were saying
this isn't going to work hey it might
have worked in talifar but this is
different this is ramadi they've had
years to consolidate this place
this is going to be it's not going to
work they were high level
people who thought that not only was we
were we gonna fail but we were gonna go
in there and get a bunch of our guys
killed for nothing
no doubt no doubt and colonel mcfarland
had a different attitude which is like
okay well we're going to try and win
and he i don't you know i wouldn't say
that he looked at it
here's our exact plan that we're going
to execute and i can i wish i could
think of all the times i saw that guy
pivot and change his mind and make an
adjustment
and and and take input from his
battalion commanders or take input from
a company commander out there in the
field and
talk to him and say what do you need and
the guy said i need this or we should do
that he'd say that sounds like a good
idea and he'd execute on it i mean he
had it
he had that kind of mind but the mind
was well i didn't mean to interrupt your
mind was
we're we're going to try and we're going
to try and stabilize
ramadan when does it first take over
when did this happen
i got there in april i'd have to it was
about it was about three weeks to a
month then
so you got there was there was there a
shift that came down all the way to the
troop level that people realized like
okay we're not we're
we're gonna start we're gonna take this
city
um
well so there were some there were some
units that
stayed so the first the 506 was there
and they they had been scrapping it out
um
the three eight marines were there in
downtown they'd been scrapping out the
first the 506 was over on eastern ramadi
they've been scrapping out
those guys had been just in a dog fight
um but yeah it took a little bit of time
to come up with
like okay hey we understand what we're
going to do how what is this actually
going to look like and and he so it
wasn't a shock to anybody no one was
like wait what's happening right now no
it's like hey this is what we're going
to do
we're going to start we're going to
start putting some some combat outposts
in and throughout ramadi i think a lot
of people have you know from the outside
have this it's really easy to get this
idea the u.s military is just so
advanced and
everything is in place that once we
decide we're going to take a city it's
like all right reach into the
reach into the file pull out plan two
alpha and now
execute we had to you know think about a
city with half a million people in it
that's been
in control of the enemy for maybe up to
two years
and now you gotta go figure out how to
take that city i mean that is a
vast undertaking and a complicated one
it's not just military in nature
okay so let me let me let me go into a
little bit more detail on this
so we did know
and as soon as i got there you know i
knew that ramadi was important but when
i got there i realized
that it was a strategic
it was a strategic decisive
element of this war and we needed to win
so what did that look like when we
showed up there
this was going to be a this was going to
be
a fallujah style
kinetic push through the city of ramadi
that's what was going to happen and we
were going to do it
during the kind of during the turnover
between
the two two eight and the one one a d so
we have
double the forces that we need we're
gonna and
and for me i'm like awesome
hey awesome we're gonna go hey guys get
ready
we're getting ready to we're getting
ready to smash this city we're getting
ready to do a fallujah
you know it's gonna be a nasty two
months get ready
you know that's what that's what
everyone was thinking okay
well in this timeframe we would have to
check the notes on this one
but maliki takes over
yes as prime minister do you have the
dates on that do you know when that was
april 22nd
right when you chopped in so
he takes over we're planning this big
kinetic smash
and he comes out and says no
we're not doing it that way and this was
a very politically
savvy move politically savvy move
because what it would have looked like
had we done it that way it would have
been
the shia government going out
and destroying a sunni city
and killing a bunch of sunnis and he
didn't want to do that
he was smart and so he said listen
you need to secure ramadi you need to do
it
with more with a scalpel not with a
hammer
that's what needs to happen and
okay so we we
one of the first missions that we did
was and this is just kind of tell you
where things do get political sometimes
so we
we chopped over to and this was this is
when it was still
colonel ground screen the 228. we
chopped over
to or we went over to the east side of
ramadi and we're gonna do a big
push like a three-day push through
this area called the malab district and
we were you know gonna go in take a
bunch of
air take a bunch of city blocks hold up
for the night
move you know stay there the next night
take a bunch of more city blocks stay
there until we got this whole area
secure
and almost like a fallujah style type
thing right so
um the battalion commander gets like
basically shut down
um and gets told hey listen we're not
doing any this was sort of the
limitations that got put on
we're not doing any we're not going to
do any
battalion sized operations no battalion
sized operations
that was the instructions and he was
like okay roger that so like he put
whatever it was four companies plus
something
like we had all the combat power we
needed but we didn't you know we weren't
under battalion command or whatever
so those are the kind of adjustments
that got made and and
but that was sort of one of the initial
operations that we did
but it wasn't the concerted strategy to
hold it was going to be a clear
and then and that was actually you know
that's the um the blue on blue from
extreme ownership
is that first big giant clearance
operation
so once we did that um and then that's
kind of when the 1-1 ad showed up and
that's when this idea said
it was hey you're not doing this we're
going to do it a different way
and mcfarlane had mcfarland had the plan
you start setting up cops around the
city yeah
that's the plan if only we're that easy
yeah i say we just let this one run i
want to hear about this
i mean what are we at an hour are you
guys gonna have to wait
check yeah like i said
if only it was that easy
stand by you can also check out our
other podcasts
i got a podcast called jaco podcast
i got a podcast called the warrior kid
podcast and i got a podcast called
grounded and daryl has a podcast
which is called martyr made then you can
support all these podcasts
by getting some gear from either the
jocko
store jackostore.com or from origin
maine
origin maine.com until next time
this is jocko and daryl out